[Music]
I'm gonna start with a statement that I
will not spend any time supporting but
you've heard this many times before
lambda-cdm is really well with the
observed large-scale structure of the
universe and so that's the pie chart
you've seen very often leading to
predictions for the large-scale
structure and on large scales it is
really hard to get around this CBM is
the right description there's just so
many things it gets right that if I had
to like build another model and cross
these hurdles it's just hard to imagine
that jumping through all these hurdles
without falling down at some point right
so that that's sort of the-- the
starting point which is that a theory
with cold non-interacting dark matter
does right you know is the right
description but then when you go to
smaller scales and you start asking you
know how cold is the particle have to be
or does the particle really have to be
non-interacting that's one interesting
things happen you know that's when you
realize that you know you can make sort
of a wholesale order one change and
still keep all of these successes so no
preamble I'm just going to jump into
this right the dominant you know view in
the past in terms of dark matter has
been you know thinking about
supersymmetric sectors where the
lightest supersymmetric particle is
it'll be the dark matter and I might
still be true that a small fraction of
the Dark Matter might still come from
that sector but people have since then
expanded their ideas about the dark
matter some of it has to do from
top-down like thinking about new ways of
producing dark matter in general
thinking about and physics that gives
rise to dark sectors some of it has to
do with the fact that we haven't really
found the Dark Matter we are looking for
and so Dark Sector particle
have you know if you talk to a lot of
the young particle physicists you know
these are dark sectors are things that
we play with right and they're not very
mysterious things for example I would
classify a sterile neutrino as a dark
sector or dark matter in the sense that
well in the sense that you know it is it
is physics as accessible in terms of
astrophysics but it's separated from
ours by some really high scale physics
so talking about and so when you have
the a dark sector there's no real reason
specifically to pick a dark matter
particle to be the TeV hundred DB scale
could be light and as soon as you say
those words you realize that the dark
matter can interact with itself right
there's really nothing prohibiting it
right so so that's sort of the basic
motivation is that we really have a very
good idea about dark matter and how it
interacts with the standard model we can
constrain it very well but when it comes
to the dark sector or the dark matter
interacting with itself we really have
no constraints the things I'm going to
show you are really the only way to get
it you know get at it all right so now
when I talk about si DM essentially self
interacting dark matter is CDM on large
scales in the sense that will give you
back the same CMB will give you back the
same large-scale structure so anywhere
you ever read in a paper lambda-cdm feel
free to replace it with lambda is i DM
you can construct a model that has
identical and you know you don't have to
jump through in hoops hoops to do this
it's by it's a particle essentially the
only difference between the coal dark
matter and NS eidm are these
interactions and interactions between
the particles really don't do anything
to change the large-scale structure now
you can build models where the dark
sector because of the way it is set up
changes the power spectrum but those
happen on pretty small scales okay and
I'm not going to talk about that aspect
it's very interesting aspect but that's
sort of more cosmology this this talk is
more about the astrophysics alright so
here's my model for you it's a model
that's actually motivated by the
phenomenology of rotation curves and
I'll go into this more in just a bit
like I said the original si diem
phenomenology was proposed by Spergel
and Steinhardt the thing I'm going to
talk about is a very specific
incarnation a realization of that and it
says basically that you know at low
velocities so velocity is accessible in
galaxies so tens to hundreds of
kilometers hundred kilometers per second
the cross-section of interaction over
the mass of the Dark Matter particle is
a few centimeter square per gram right
it's essentially off order bonds per GeV
so if your Dark Matter particle is is a
GeV mass then the cross-section is a
bond right so here it's a big
cross-section it's close to the nuclear
cross section as I allude to in just a
bit but this cross-section cannot okay
so the reason why else I'll show you why
this is interesting is because when you
allow for this cross section you
actually get very simple predictions for
the Dark Matter halo and it fits
galaxies rotation curves really well
okay and again I'll go into this in some
depth the other reason I actually like
this is because these cross-sections are
large enough that the scattering
timescales become short enough that the
dark where it gets driven to equilibrium
and they get driven to equilibrium
quickly enough that they become
insensitive to a star formation history
what does this mean it means that the
final Dark Matter distribution depends
on the baryon distribution at the end
and not so much how you actually brought
the baryons together again we'll talk
more about this but this is not true for
all as idea models like you knock down
this cross-section
then this is not gonna be true because
the time scales are now gonna be fast
enough but when you have cross-sections
of order few you know three four five
and could be much larger it could be ten
twenty then this is true but also you
cannot have this cross-section be
velocity independent and that's the
really exciting part in terms of model
building this cross-section must fall
with velocity because we know from
observations of clusters and it's not
the bullet cluster its measurements of
the densities of clusters through
lensing for example and kinematics we
know that the cross you know you cannot
support a cross-section that's that big
it's just completely inconsistent with
clusters so by the time you go from a
hundred kilometers per second to a
cluster which is the thousand kilometers
couple of thousand kilometers per second
the cross-section must fall that's the
only way you can build a viable model
now this might seem you know where did
this velocity dependence come from let
me just give you a motivating standard
model example okay this is just the
scattering a plot of the scattering
cross-section for protons and neutrons
alternately you can just think of it as
Neutron Neutron no collisions on the y
axis is the cross-section on the x axis
is the incident energy in MeV alright
this is twenty bonds is the famous
twenty pounds
nuclear cross-section and if I were to
think of this as Dark Matter scattering
so for a moment imagine that the Dark
Matter particle the dominant Dark Matter
particle is just a stable hidden Neutron
so a stable dark do Tron imagine a Dark
Sector where there's a neutron and it's
stable right in in the standard model
for all we know the fact that the
neutron is unstable and the proton is
alight is as an accident you could just
easily switch this around in the dark
sector just imagine it's a neutral
particle in the dark secret that's
stable and
this was the way it interacted right
just scattering all this is this pure
elastic scattering then in clusters
you'd be accessing velocities here these
incident energies turn into like
thousand kilometer per second velocities
right so bullet cluster and things like
that like this muscular part cluster
which are these merging clusters you
would be accessing velocities in and
that range a rotation curves would be
sensitive to velocities here right so
you could imagine taking different
objects from dwarf galaxies to somewhat
larger galaxies to clusters and actually
getting this curve and surprisingly
actually this curve that's a pretty good
job you know probably you I would ship
this a little bit to the left but other
than that a neutron proton of just a
nuclear cross-section is this a
geometric but of course here it's not
geometric because now you can you know
there's the binding energy for deuterium
right so it is this this starts falling
because you have enough momentum but yes
this this is essentially just coming
from the neutron proton cross-section so
in terms of model building what you need
but basically you need to mass scales to
build in a velocity dependence okay one
of the masks else is just the mass of
the Dark Matter particle that's there in
every single model right the other one
is what sets the velocity dependence so
yes this would be related to the PI on
mass but it's it's it's not which it's
not just QCD right I mean this is
nuclear physics so yeah it's related to
it but it's a more complicated
calculation all right but you know if
you're just thinking of just a an
elementary Fermi on then there's some
mediator of the force between them and
then the mass of that mediator
divided by the mass of the Dark Matter
essentially sets the scale of the
velocity dependence so if the mediator
mass of the Dark Matter mass is let's
say ten to the minus three then when B
over C is about a 10 to the minus
which is Milky Way you will start seeing
a velocity dependence the cross-section
would start falling all right so this
this this fall here is you know it's
related to again it depends on what the
model is if it's like I said it's simple
you Kaba potential then it's related to
the mediated mass over the Dark Matter
mass you could have something else like
a Dark Sector atom imagine that the dark
matter is like the hydrogen atom in that
case is the ratio of the electron to
proton mass right so you just need you
need two scales in the problem
all right that's that's that's what I'm
saying to build this in and this is not
you don't have to bend over backwards
it's just there you know if if you had a
hydrogen hydrogen scattering you would
have this basically the curve would look
the same but you shifted in energies so
velocity dependence is is not you know
something baroque just think of it as
something part and parcel of the model
you're building you know the one example
where you might get a scattering that's
where you will get a scattering this
velocity independent is if for example
the pi ons are your dark matter a dark
pile and they are mediating through ion
exchange you know that's essentially
going to be you know velocity
independent alright so there's no dearth
of models like this all right and I like
this you know I you know maybe there is
something to this similarity between
what I want here for rotation curves and
what we have in our own standard model
which is the nuclear cross section of
order 10 bonds right so you know
remember this is you know the QCD scale
is not something you need to put in by
hand right it comes you know from this
running of the coupling constant when it
when it actually becomes really strong
right 100 MeV scale sort of falls out of
it right so there's something very neat
about the nuclear cross section so I
kind of like it for that reason right
maybe this is a clue that there's a QCD
like structure in the Dark Sector
nature's done it once why not twice all
right
so first I'm going to talk about how
this model are presented the simple
model of just elastic scattering and
nothing else
imagine the dark matter does what cold
dark matter does but in addition
scatters off of each other elastically
what is it due to Galactic halos so
here's a one slide you need to
understand this there's two plots here
this plot is telling you about sort of
the effective temperature so is the RMS
velocity of the dark matter in a halo
plotted against the radial distance from
the center of the halo they've been both
scaled by some typical velocity so V max
is the maximum circular velocity you
would get in that halo and RS is is
related to you know where that maximum
happens okay so the maximum would happen
at two times roughly speaking RS what so
what this is telling you is that so the
black points are CDM cold arc medicine
no no elastic scattering right and so
you see this familiar feature which is
that the inner part of a cold dark
matter halo is cold that's how you use
stuff more and more particles and you
get the central density curst and then
it's sort of like grad you gradually
letõs out here you know roughly speaking
it's kind of isothermal out here what
happens as you crank up the
cross-section so at 0.1 centimeter
square per gram nothing much happens you
can sort of see some changes here but
when you have one centimeter square per
gram what's happening is because of
these interactions right now remember
what's happening is you know dark matter
particles are on these long or you know
on these orbits right so you have
particles coming from the outside
interacting with particles in the inner
part and eventually if the outer part is
harder then the inner part you'll start
transferring energy inside there's a
gradient in the temperature think of it
that way and there's an effective
transfer of energy from inside out and
so over time and this is after thirteen
billion years you can sort of see that
the four one centimeter square per gram
the inner part is become isothermal
that's that's basically it all you've
done
what hydrogen atoms doing this room
right they scatter off of each other and
equalize the temperature but it does
something pretty interesting in a galaxy
unlike this room which is when the
scattering happened since you transfer
energy in the particles here that gain
the energy move two orbits that have
longer a percenters right there who's a
person is a further away and so you push
particles out in this process because
you're dumping energy into this right
and you can kind of see that here you
sort of start out with this kospi
profile so this is the density as a
function of radius and then as you
transfer energy in and get isothermal
you've taken this mass here and pushed
it out here so you can see that there's
more mass here in this IDM and you make
a pretty big change to the density in
the inner part now this is interesting
because it sort of creates cores and you
know this this might be something that's
that's you know that when you look at
data you can prove or disprove but if
this were the story
this model will be dead it would be
pretty uninteresting okay the story is
actually a you know a lot more
interesting as I'll try it will tell you
now okay so I want to pause here and ask
like are there any questions about this
because we're going to just use this and
not much else for the rest of the talk
in terms of the physics so the inner
part yes which is then which is the next
slide which is which is the critical
part of already you know if it wasn't
for that then I would say like I was
saying you know this this wouldn't be a
working model all right so I will divide
up this region into you know this is
this is sort of a very simple picture we
can think of a region that's isothermal
in here and then we outer part where the
scattering sort of been really
ineffective by the way I am you know the
scattering cross-section is big like ten
bonds right but I
here in this region most of the halo has
barely interacted so this is sort of the
region where you had one interaction
over the edge of the halo and that's
just because the Dark Matter is so
diffuse right even with this big nuclear
cross section most of the matter 90% of
the manor outside has not really
interacted right but in the inner region
they've interacted so that's the inner
core okay so in the outer part it look
like the cold dark matter which is this
number of Frank white profile in the
inner part will be isothermal so very
simple model and this is where the
baryons come in and makes it really
interesting it's kind of amazing how
simple it is I mean this is like stat
mech 101 you know so if the inner part
is isothermal what does that really mean
it means that the distribution is
maxwellian
right that's what the scheduling is
going to do it's going to make the
distribution inside maxwellian well max
Fillion you know you know what it is
erase t minus ei over KT integrate out
the velocities the kinetic energy what
are you left with just the gravitational
potential
so again basic stat mech tells you that
the in the inner part once you be clear
it right if the time scale for
scattering is fast enough then the
density profile of the self interacting
Dark Matter has to look like earase to
minus the gravitational potential over
KT with KT is the temperature right and
what is the temperature know that the
temperature of the dark matter and
that's essentially just you know this V
RMS and what is V RMS you can kind of
see it's like 1.2 times V Max so it
means just set by the maximum circular
velocity of the halo so you pick a halo
you see where it's circular velocity is
2 you basically know where the
temperature is going to be for a large
enough cross-section now you're asking a
hard question then then you have to
factor that in so the temperature will
depend on both the CDM and this idea so
the temperature depends on everything
that's inside all of the matter
all right so so Phi over KT but this Phi
remember is the gravitational potential
of everything that's inside there
doesn't matter whether it's dark matter
or baryons so in particular if you have
a galaxy but the baryons dominate the
inner part like our Milky Way then the
then the density profile of the dark
matter will just follow the potential of
the barians it's pretty neat right it's
exactly the opposite of what everyone
had predicted when they first did these
simulations which is that when the
scattering happens the dark matter is
just going to become puffy and spherical
right but that's that's not what happens
for example when baryons dominate in the
milky way the dark matter in the central
part of milky wave in SI DM is shaped
like the potential of the milky way
which is sort of like a squashed right
so it's actually squashed it's not
spherical at all and if if you actually
do this for the milky way simulated with
a milky way disk in there then the
density profile of si DM is basically
like that of C DM or even a little bit
higher so there's no real core in this
which is you know and it's all got to do
with the bearing ones right now if my
cross-section were not that high then I
would not be able to make these
predictions with any great degree of
like confidence because then your
results will depend as it should on the
feedback it'll depend on what the
baryons are doing right we hear what I'm
saying is you give it a billion years or
so the equilibrium solution will well
you know you have to get to the
equilibrium in that time and then your
solution has to look like this I don't
care what happened before that it only
depends on the final distribution of the
variance that's why I you know I you
know I went to this part of parameter
space where the where the cross-section
was large enough because it's a total
potential no it's it absolutely yeah so
you have to solve it
yes but I gave you just an example of
the Milky Way we're in the center it's
dominated by by the barrier but in
general that's not true so in a Dwarfs
for L it'll be the other way around
which is the baryons are unimportant and
then you do get a core and in that case
there's a very interesting thing which
is you don't get there's no new scale in
this problem with a large cross-section
the only scale and the problem is this
RS and that's because when the
cross-section is fairly large you
basically become isothermal all the way
out right so your core that you create
is basically of the same scale as the
NFW scale radius so in a strange way
this is basically everything is
determined by just the coal Dark Matter
properties by RS and andro s or V Max
and R max in this model there isn't one
absolutely so we've looked at for
example yeah yeah absolutely so for
example like we've looked at you know
what if it's a dark hydrogen atom in
which case there's the analog of the 21
centimeter line and that can L allow you
to allow dissipation or in clusters you
can have interactions where you bump up
and energy level and then scatter it
back down so it's possible to do that
depends on the model but the what the
thing I'm presenting to you right now is
this the simple bare bones only yes so
if if you allow for dissipation and if
you allow for cooling then it'll
certainly change the solution but I
don't know I haven't written down a
model where the cooling is that
important all of the ones I've looked at
the cooling is at the 10% level at best
it's possible people have looked at this
there are there are other simulations
with cooling like Mark Vogel's burgers
done a few simulations Tracy slide here
my focus burger they looked at this
alright so you know the only only other
thing you would need to remember is that
there are no new parameters in this
model it's only the NFW or the coal Dark
Matter parameters and that's because you
know there's two free parameters your T
and Rho naught right but they're not
free because you know you won this model
you want this profile this profile which
is isothermal to smoothly match onto the
outer profile right so whatever is the
outer profile they'll determine what
happens in the inner part so you just
like in cerium there's two free
parameters in in cerium typically we
take that to be like you know V Max and
our max and those are the same free
parameters so there's no new free
parameters when you're fitting to halo
profiles all right so let's look at so
there's one more bit of physics now
before we move on to showing you what
how what it does the rotation curve and
that's a very interesting bit of physics
which is let me just go back to this
figure here again so I you know this
thing became isothermal right now
imagine running it forward in time a
little bit more right this whole thing
is I so you know it's getting isothermal
in the center what happens now so
remember initially our you know my
entire argument was based on
transferring heat from outside in now
when this is isothermal right you're not
longer transferring heat from outside in
right because this part is harder than
the outer part over long timescales you
start transferring energy from inside
out so you're transferring energy from
inside out which is you cooling these
particles right but since this is a
gravitational system what's happening is
these particles get you know in the
basically get into smaller orbits right
so you you concentrate them more towards
the center that increases the
gravitational potential that makes it
harder right so as you cool you get
harder gravitational systems right it's
a negative heat capacity and so what
will happen is this will start getting
harder and harder
you will keep transferring more and more
energy outside and that's a gravel
thermal runaway process so all SI TM
halos will eventually go through this
grab a thermal collapse and turn in
principle into black holes yeah this is
this is something very interesting but
yes there is this prediction that every
SI DM halo given enough time will host a
black hole at the center but you'll see
how this can get accelerated that was
the end of this talk all right so here's
a concrete I you know the simulation
instead of running time forward here
what's been done so this is from James
Bullock's group what they've done here
is they've run different cross sections
so for people at the back this is 0.1
centimeter square 0.5 1 5 10 50 so 0.1
0.5 1 okay and then 5 and then look at
what is happening to 10 the density
starts increasing and then 50 the
densities gone up right so this is the
core collapse process so die you know
instead of running this is just all been
run for like 14 billion years instead of
running it longer it's just you just run
it with a larger cross section which is
basically the same thing okay and so
eventually you go through this process
where you create a core the core gets as
big as it can get which is of order RS
that scale and then you start code
collapsing okay so this is this is a
very generic process and here's a more
semi analytic model where you see this
this is an estimate of the core density
in units of sort of the NFW scale
density so that's the typical density of
the halo coal Dark Matter halo and here
is an estimate of the time in some scale
units and what you
and there's a whole bunch of
cross-sections here really doesn't
matter what you see is there's a common
envelope where they all get defuse and
less dense in the center and this part
is where you're here give this big core
and then eventually they start core
collapsing and then if you've you know
we've switched the scale from
logarithmic to a linear scale here so
that's why you see this discontinuity
and it just goes all right because it's
you know basically this this process
just is a runaway graviton will collapse
process okay now for reasonable
cross-sections or for cross-sections
we've been considering like five or ten
this doesn't really happen in Field
halos you know this this period is long
enough that you're always stuck here
okay so this dot tells you for each
given cross-section where you would be
today
so you consider it for five centimeter
square per gram you sort of at the
bottom of this you're not called
collapse but if you're at an then you're
kind of maybe starting to collapse it so
unless you're looking at cross-sections
that are very high you would think this
is irrelevant it's actually not hold on
to this I'll come back to this at the
end for now just remember the
thermalization I told you the e raise to
minus Phi over KT okay so the thing I
want to do in this talk is basically
just give you a quick glimpse on what
this does in field galaxies and then
just maybe tell you a little bit about
satellite galaxies at the end as a way
of like really
maybe falsifying this or or ruling it in
alright so rotation curves you've all
seen examples of rotation curves here is
here's you know just just an analytic
picture of what happens with rotation
curves so what's plotted here on the y
axis is the circular velocity due to the
dark matter as a function of radius so
let's just focus on the top plot here
I've assumed Sigma over m is three
centimeter square program picked a
certain halo with a maximum velocity of
70 and this band this gray band is the
prediction
of the NFW profile okay and the and the
band is coming in because of the merger
history for any given v-max there's some
range of possibilities in in a density
even within the CDM paradigm so you
remember that halos in Col dark matter
are one parameter with some scatter
that's one parameter and that's the
scanner now you turn on the
cross-section what happens like kind of
looks basically like CDM except that you
know you have this sis similar scatter
but the density in the inner part has
gone down and that's the formation of
the core
you've taken mass from inside and shop
you know push it out so you get this
core okay what would happen if there
were baryons in there so here's a plot
with the baryons and the baryons are now
put in in just in this is just an
analytic model so you take a certain
stellar mass in this case is about ten
to the ten and then you say that well
this forms a disk exponential disk of
scale length to KP c 3 KP c 6 k pc ok
and then the orange would be a case
where there's no baryons so this orange
sort of matches up with that then you
add some baryons and you see that the
density has gone up then you make the
baryons even more compact so you're
keeping the mass of the baryons fixed
but you're making it more compact and
and what you see is like the density
jacks up and here's a really compact
disk and you can see what's happening
here right it it gets you know is this
there's so much more dark matter in the
center it that the rotation curve rises
really quickly
right and that's just the e to the minus
Phi or KT if you dump more baryons in if
you make it more concentrated the
potential goes up for just the baryons
and that forces the dark matter to be
way more concentrated in the center so
as you make the baryons more compact the
dark matter becomes more dense so even
without doing anything to the
bereans and you know even without
coupling the dark matter and violence
just gravitationally the two are coupled
in this in a very intrinsic way the
baryon stell dark matter how to behave
in these models and this is just
completely gravitational and it remember
it's coming about because a
cross-section is kind of large right now
how does this fit you know how do you
see how does this fit galaxies so I'll
just give you three examples okay and
there are three really good examples
there's a lot of curves in here but
let's first focus on on the data so
again this is a rotation curve for three
different galaxies all of these galaxies
are similar to similar velocities see
that it's 80 kilometers per second here
in this galaxy you get to 80 kilometers
per second within about kpc or two okay
so this is very concentrated in stars
and dark matter you know the rise is
much more gentle look at the scale and
here it's even more gentle okay so three
galaxies with similar amounts of baryons
roughly similar amounts of dark matter
in the outer parts but behave completely
differently in the inner part what's the
difference between them and look at
these population lines and in particular
look at the thing that have denoted as
stars here the stars are distributed in
a very diffuse way so this would be a
low surface brightness galaxy here you
can see this is a prototypical high
surface brightness galaxies probably as
a small pseudo bulge in the middle you
know and you can see that the stars are
like very dominant in the center so in
this case what's happening is that the
dark matter the SI DM prediction is
essentially like this is the same as the
nfw halo right it's B in this case what
SI DM says is because there's so many
baryons in the center the dark matter
because of the e to the minus five over
KT has to be really you know dense in
the center and that's being shown by
this blue line that's the halo this
would be the case if you just neglected
the effect of the barians huge
difference right and this difference is
coming about because of the potential of
the balance but as here the dark matter
you know has this sort of big core and
Rises very gently and this is not a
unique case essentially every time you
actually see galaxies there are this
diffuse and stars it's also diffuse and
dark matter so when you've heard these
things that we know that that core cusp
issue right the issue is not really
about cores and cups the issue is that
you know there's both cores and cusps in
the data and the galaxies will you see
these big cores from what we have looked
at are always cases where the stars are
very diffuse also so the stars and dark
matter are linked together ok in this
way yeah it's is this this thing here
I'll show you comparison to the cerium
in in our in a statistical sense and in
a bit later are you asking if they have
the same amount of gas I mean in this
particular case it has roughly similar
mustard gas yeah so I'm not sure what
the question is is I mean I don't know
in particular yeah so I think it's a
good question is and and something I'll
come back to is like you know what is
the difference between these high
surface brightness and low surface
brightness galaxies right why do some
galaxies form as low surface brightness
and why do some form as high surface
brightness in although this I probably
want till you talk about this in the in
Si DM the only way you form
sort of like very diffuse and you know
galaxies is is by putting them into very
low concentration halos so these have to
be galaxies that form very late in the
universe and there are low concentration
because of that and that's that's the
way you would get these like very big
and if you use things right so it's it's
in principle a testable prediction it's
something that I'm working on now which
is that you know you expect sort of the
the most diffuse galaxies
you also have form kind of late and be
in these low concentration halos hmm
they must be super rare they can only be
like five ten percent and that's very
consistent with these kinds of systems
it cannot be more than that yeah so for
example when we did these fits we were
very very careful about asking like how
many of these to Sigma you know minus 2
Sigma things do you have and out of the
hundred or so fits we did there was like
you know five to ten so yeah you know
statistics would be interesting to do
anyway here's a compilation of 140 I
forget exactly how many but so around 40
galaxies and they're color-coded in a
way that tells you something about their
surface density so the panels are are
essentially telling you about the
maximum circular velocity so something
about the size the mass of the galaxy so
here's about 80 kilometers 100 plus 150
and then these are getting to be Milky
Way and bigger right and then the color
coding here is that blue are very
compact galaxies and then the Reds are
sort of more diffused low surface
brightness and you can sort of see it's
not perfect but you can sort of see a
sense in which you know the circular
velocity arises really quickly there and
not so much there right and the lines
are the SI diem fits and in every case
we've tried to make sure that the fits
are within sort of this to Sigma scatter
of you know that's allowed for in
hierarchical structure formation no this
is just one cross-section yeah it turns
out that the cross you know because of
this equilibrium it becomes very
insensitive to the cross-section so I
could take it to be three or four
five or ten doesn't really matter you'll
get back the same thing yeah and the
small ones is difficult I don't know I
mean I can maybe there's coal collapse
happening so might change but between
three to ten kind of they're all sort of
off order RS and that's that's just
simply because like you know you once
you once you get out to RS they the NFW
halo is already isothermal and so you
don't really change the coal size that
much by jacking it up at least in the
fits we're down to like you know fifty
kilometers per second we you know we
tried it in three four five it didn't
really change anything they look pretty
much the same in any case for this one
we just fixed it to be three centimeter
square program I will talk about this in
two slides again actually after this one
so here's just this is for the
aficionados here's what went into the
fifth so this is showing you the v-max
our max relation this is the Darden at
all relation from for Planck and that's
the two sigma scatter and I'm just
telling showing you that all of the fits
we did lie within that this is the
stellar mass halo mass relation and this
one's the Barozzi where is ease fit you
know sort of see that you know they're
they all look reasonable nothing
untoward this is the baryonic tell
official relation and the orange pants
in the background or what you would I
know get from on like fed again you know
they look perfectly reasonable right and
they're all coming from this very simple
idea of of you know something being
isothermal e to the minus Phi over KT
okay so so as far as we can tell
taking everything we know from cosmology
it gives you a very simple way to
understand the Dark Matter halos of
galaxies right now I haven't told you
yet where you know why some galaxies are
high surface
whiteness versus loss of aliveness you
know whatever happens you know you need
feedback just to you know create stars
in the disk and get the right amount of
stars in the right galaxies right
feedbacks part of you know galaxy's life
you cannot avoid that what I'm telling
you is that the dark matter in this
model is nailed out right the final
prediction for the dark matter is nailed
on and that's that it makes it very
predictive all right what about other
models right I'm not a big fan of like
doing this because I think the model
that I've presented to you stands on its
own but it's kind of interesting to ask
what is it - better than existing models
this is a little bit of a complicated
plot but let me just show you what it is
this is one specific groups cerium
simulations so they are the Niihau
simulations very successful you know
beautiful set of simulations and in the
background you can see sort of the
rotation curves they're generated those
are the gray ones and the data for a few
galaxies are shown by these data points
and then the solid lines are the aside
'i'm fit so for now just disregard the
aside IAM fits just compare the data to
the gray points right what you take away
from this is that already in in modern
simulations with you know the feedback
is getting you the right stellar mass
halo mass relation is getting you
roughly the right median sizes for the
galaxies they can make cores right and
that's a part and parcel of the feedback
process you can see this this is a big
core right but what I would argue from
this what is going wrong is that the
feedback is strong enough not just to
create a core but it also makes the
stars less you know more diffuse right
because stars the collision is dark -
collision as you do something the Dark
Matter you probably do it to the stars -
right and the way I see that is that you
know you can see that these galaxies are
the ones that are not produced right and
it's not an issue with rotation curves
it's just the sizes you
just don't make make enough compact
galaxies with this feedback method so in
my mind I think this is a clue that you
know what we have in terms of the
feedback models is not quite right I
think that's kind of exciting that you
know you you know it's no longer enough
to just get the median properties right
you have to get the scatter right you
want to be able to explain why you know
as George was asking why are there high
surface brightness and low surface
brightness galaxies how do you get both
ends right it's not enough to get one of
the ends right so as far as I can tell
they didn't I mean looking at the papers
and asking few people they didn't do
anything specifically different in terms
of selecting the their zoom ins web
pages you don't maybe maybe that's
that's that's the case right but I would
say you're missing a good half of this
it's not just the the lowest lowest part
here so I don't know what the answer to
this is right because even in si diem
like I told you the only way you're
gonna make the very diffuse galaxies in
this idea is if they are the low
concentration ones right so my claim
would be that the concentration is
intrinsically related to the galaxy
properties which is not the dominant
view in terms of like you know thinking
about galaxy formation right it doesn't
you know people haven't really been
saying that is the concentration that
actually drives things at least at the
for the low concentration more diffuse
ones I would say at least in si D I'm
the only way to get them right is is if
they're born in the low concentration
halos and the low concentration really
means they formed late that's the
interesting part right and so there is
actually a predicting you know there's a
predictive power here right if you could
actually take a bunch of blue surface
brightness galaxies know enough of their
star formation history and actually see
when the you know the when most of the
stars formed not an easy thing to do I
think
but in principle it's possible
you should be able to test this you
should be able to test that the low
surface brightness galaxies are on
average younger then a high surface
brightness galaxies alright just in
terms of like statistical fits you know
this is for the hundred odd galaxies you
are looking at this is the CDF of the
Chi square per degrees of freedoms just
what fraction of the galaxies are well
fit with a certain guy square degree of
freedom and you can sort of see as IBM
is doing pretty much as well as you can
imagine it's going to do Chi square per
degree of freedom of one it's about 70
percent of the galaxies right so it is
doing the right thing and the right
thing is correlate the baryons and Dark
Matter in a certain way right which is
when the dark matter is less dense it's
also the barians or less dense or
vice-versa right and this is the DC 14
which is a fit to the Niihau simulations
right and it's also you know it doesn't
do as well as this IDM because of that
you know I think mostly because the high
surface brightness n but it does better
than just an NFW fit which is this black
line and this magenta is the Mond
or the radial acceleration relation bond
does really well at fitting the median
but it does a horrible job of explaining
the scarer right so if you've ever been
told that Mont fits galaxies well it's
just not true it is it is giving you
sort of the median relation right that's
what was built on but it doesn't do a
good job of like you know sitting in
galaxy by galaxy I'm gonna skip through
this so that was my if you want like
this this is this is my main motivation
for you and why I gave you that model
that was based on the rotation curves
because it does such a great job of
fitting the rotation curves okay and
it's
I think that in at the end in all these
models as the thing is how do you get
the galaxy's right yeah I mean like then
in the Niihau that's that's this case
yeah so I think it really boils down to
like now getting the full range right
and I would say the other thing is in my
view you know with si diem now you have
a lot more freedom in how you build a
feedback model because you know at the
end of the day that dark matter is going
to come out right it's not a constraint
you put on your feedback models you want
to just get the baryons right right
however you do the baryons the dark
matter will do what I just told you and
that's that's that's the neat part about
you know there's this model alright so
you know I cannot claim this is at this
point I'm not standing it and saying
that it is si diem and not cerium why am
I not doing that because of what sort of
dushyant's like referent which is if you
don't understand the feedback within CD
I am it's hard to say it's ruled out
because maybe there's another feedback
model there that actually give you
everything correct and if that's the
case we need something else to break the
degeneracy and I claim that there is
down the road let's say we understand
feedback in both of these models well
enough then the satellite galaxies will
function as you know as a way of
breaking the two you know the beach and
recei between these models and that has
to do with you know this curve I showed
you partly so here's the next bit of
physics one one slide that we need to
know so this curve I showed you tells
you about the evolutions you just look
at the solid curve first you start out
at high density in the early universe so
that's essentially like an nfw halo as
time goes on your density decreases
and normally has told you that you know
for any reasonable cross-section you're
sort of in this in this ballpark
but if you have a satellite galaxy and
it falls into the main halo as it orbits
the main halo it's going to lose mass
and as it loses mass what's happening is
the outer heat bath all of the dark
matter particles ever in the outer part
that was sort of the heat bath you lose
that and so now you go through this
process of core collapse much quicker
and if you haven't thought of this in
this context an easier thing to think of
is remember globular clusters globular
clusters have a similar phenomenon where
eventually they go through this process
of cold collapse okay and the same thing
is happening here okay slightly
different reasons but it's a similar
physics as you lose mass this process by
which you start turning around and core
collapse happens quicker okay
and now a satellite galaxy even for
cross-sections about a five centimeter
square per gram if you strip enough mass
in the outer part depends a little bit
on the orbit we can actually go through
this core collapse process right and the
densities can be much much much higher
than what is is in the field and this
you know is something that's really
unique to si diem because you can get
densities that are higher than you even
in cold out matter model because you
have this core collapse our process
happening I mean in this in this picture
when I'm talking about the dwarf
galaxies the stars are irrelevant
essentially but in plan in practice if
there were stars around them they will
follow the dark matter along with a
media by de creus so that so so there is
yes so again in this case idiomatically
when you push the dark matter in you
would expect with the Stars for
and so the size of the the compactness
of the stars should be related to that
of the Dark Matter the flipside is also
true so for example Zavala and Fogle's
located some simulations where they
showed that you know as in a field as
the Dark Matter density gets low since
you're removing mass from the inner part
the stars just a dramatically expand and
so it just makes things shallow right so
the sizes of the stars a stellar disk is
set by the Dark Matter
in that case and so in this case yes the
opposite should happen all right so let
me try to just show you one plot of this
and then I'll go to the summary so
here's an example of what happens in a
satellite so this solid line is the CDM
as you increase the cross-section what I
want to show you is that you know this
is for a particular orbit where instead
of the density going down you see this
for cross section of order three this
density no sadler is actually higher
than CDM in fact if I jack it up to ten
and ten is totally reasonable nothing
rules this out okay because this is a
small velocity it's completely called
collapsed and eventually this portion of
it if nothing else stops it it's going
to turn into some fraction of this will
turn into a black hole and the time
scales are fairly quick for that to
happen
right so it really just depends on the
cross section right so there is this
other prediction within this s idea
model which I know surprisingly no one's
really sort of worked out which is that
you know you expect a spectrum of black
holes again depends on the concentration
depends a little bit on how you know
what the the orbits are but you know
that fish you know that's there um
here's here's another orbit and the
difference between this and this is
concentration this is the high
concentration halo so it formed pretty
early this is a low concentration halo
it's low concentration so the time
scales are pretty long and you never get
to this core collapse process as time
goes on as you can see the density just
keeps going down from zero to three to
ten so so an SI DM you can get a huge
amount of diversity you can get these
like really compact one over R square
profiles and you can get this
huge force and that's you know once once
we understand this and being able to
sort of like you know compare this to
the CDN predictions I think this this
provides a pretty unique way to like try
to like distinguish them all right let
me just what maybe one more slide this
is it isn't these are not just true for
like satellite galaxies they would be
also true for these dark sub halos that
people have been looking for you both in
gravitational lensing and through
effects on the stellar streams in the
Milky Way so for example there is a
detection with gd1 stellar stream and
here's an example from Simona which at
his work her first detection of off of a
dark sub halo and either detection has
been shown to be really consistent with
CDM they in fact very compact and maybe
this is a signature of core collapse I
don't know but what I'm trying to tell
you is that there are in principle
differences between SI TM and cerium
when you when you're thinking about
satellites and sub halos and that might
be the way to break the degeneracy
between the two models alright so let me
just put this up and say that you know
the simple model that I presented is is
an excellent description of Dark Matter
halos consistent with all known
observations nothing rules this out okay
I'm trying very hard to like you know
break it as of now it hasn't broken and
I would say as of now it does explain
phenomena that cannot be currently
explained within the CDM model maybe
this will change I don't really know but
what I'm really excited about are the
last things that told you that there are
concrete avenues to falsify it using
satellite galaxies and hopefully in a
couple of months there will be sort of
this online review so this is supposed
to be a living review there's a similar
living review on sort of dark energy
that's already out let my proven hgn you
can go to novel probes dot-org so there
will be a similar review on sida i'm
just putting together all of the
different ways in which SI TM effects
small-scale structure galaxy sorry for
[Applause]
you